what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I think it's safe to say the
cosmic ghostwriter was like the standout
star of the Thanos series uh you know
but if dr. Baines hear that this kind of
picks up after the events of like well
not really fan OHS war but after the
events of like Thanos wins basically
when he grabs his younger self for you
into the future and then the two of them
fight and so on and so forth but cosmic
Ghost Rider had died in that battle at
the hands of the Silver Surfer willing
the hammer of Thor now close the guys
who were not familiar a little bit of
catch-up here for those of you guys who
didn't see our video on cosmic Ghost
Rider the origin of his character cosmic
Ghost Rider's Frank Castle he's the
Punisher the idea behind this was that
somewhere along the line during Thanos's
you know eventual conquest of the
universe leading to some three million
years in the future whatever it was that
he had basically destroyed everything uh
he'd arrived on earth and like wiped out
all the superheroes and Frank Hass was
one of the people who died but in his
last moments Frank Castle had basically
said like I would give anything to kill
this guy and the result was that Frank
Castle was brought before Mephisto who
in turn bonded him with the spirit of
vengeance and Frank Castle went forward
his Ghost Rider but as we know with
Mephisto the whole idea behind this was
that there's always a caveat and the
caveat here was that basically Frank
Castle was confined to earth with no one
to really defeat but he would presumably
live for eternity unless some external
power greater than his own decided to
annihilate and now of course that led
into Galactus showing up and then giving
him the power cosmic he went forward as
Galactus is Herald and then ultimately
met Thanos and of course we know the
rest from the from the Thanos miniseries
but still it's a pretty cool concept
here and it's pretty interesting because
following all that what this does is
this basically picks up with this fight
between Frank castle in Valhalla and
just some other minor guy there's a very
significant it's just a guy who's there
but of course here's one of the things
that I want to talk about for a second I
want to kind of address this this idea
of death in in Marvel Comics and how
death works so in Marvel originally back
in the day like what I see back in the
day I mean like when Jack Kirby was
writing tales of Asgard so we could say
from the early 1960s when Thor first
showed up and journey into mystery
running all the way up to around 1970
1971 when Jack Kirby left uh what you
had is you just had the realm of hell
and that was it that was the only place
people go when they die that's all there
was to it the way the death was split up
is you had Odin who is bubut who is
basically in charge of deciding who gets
to go to Valhalla and who doesn't and
then you had the realm of help with
those who died an honorable combat if
selected them then the Valkyries would
retrieve their spirit and they would
take them to Valhalla where did we spend
eternity alongside their their warriors
and it would tell tales of their crazy
battles and so on and so forth and there
would be worshipped by denizens on earth
who believed in the Asgardian mythos
everybody else went to the realm of Hell
and that was it that's all there was to
it
it wasn't until mistress death Mephisto
the idea of there actually being a
judeo-christian heaven a judeo-christian
version of health but you saw all these
seven versions and he's different you
know iterations of death being rolled in
to Marvel Comics and so the way it
stands right now there really is no
absolute standard you have those who go
to the realm of hella you have those who
go to the realm of mistress death you
have those who go to bed judeo-christian
heaven those who go to the
judeo-christian hell which is basically
ran by Satan you have those who were
tricked by Mephisto who steals their
souls and then there they're you know
going to spend all eternity trapped in
his realm I mean there's all different
kinds of things that go on in the realm
of death but for this little section
right here one thing to remember is that
Valhalla is like a part of Asgard proper
which is to say like it's a section over
there somewhere and so those who were
selected by Odin basically reside here
and because of the fact that Frank
castle had you know perished an
honorable battle against the Silver
Surfer wielding the hammer of Thor this
basically meant that Frank castle was
now going to be you know going to exist
among the honor debt the problem with
Frank Castle is he can never find true
peace remember Frank castles entire
existence is governed by the desire to
destroy you know evildoers in order to
satisfy his blood lust basically to you
know ensure that his charter his
existence remains intact it's not really
anything tangible it's just that's what
he does that's the whole basis behind
his character and so because that while
he's in Valhalla he's been picking
fights with everybody but he's been
fighting what he considers to be bad
guys you know like one of these guys for
example killed kids during some major
conflict it he had and so Frank castles
like that guy's got to go well because
you can't kill people in Valhalla he
just cuts off his nose and that's really
the end of that but when Odin starts
talking to Frank Castle Frank castles
response is like I don't really want to
be here like there there are things out
there that I need to attend to but
remember and this this future this you
know three million years or whatever in
the world it is in the future there's
really nothing to attend to anymore like
nothing really exists and so there's
really nothing left I mean it's it would
literally be Frank Castle riding around
the cosmos stepping on cockroaches more
or less and so ah the result is that
that still he what he wants to do now
when it comes to this whole thing
Odin says look I brought you
here as a service but if you don't want
to be here I won't make you stay here
and so he's like you can leave anytime
you want I've kept your motorcycle I've
kept your spirit of engines you can you
can take off and so Freight castle is
like fine I want to leave then Odin's
like okay well if you're you know in for
a penny in for a pound you leave you
take everything with you and so we
basically you know forces the cosmic
Ghost Rider the spirit of vengeance back
on a friend Castle even though he
doesn't want it and then of course Frank
Castle goes forward as cosmic Ghost
Rider again so this is what basically
sets the stage for what's going on right
now in this moment out with regards to
you know the future of this miniseries
now from here Frank Castle and this is
kind of an interesting thing and in
Marvel what Donnie Cates does here
Donnie Cates gives himself an out and
it's actually the smartest way to do
that some you won't say it's not but
Donnie Cates is is he's not doing what
Bendis does right like what Brian Bendis
will do it's you'll write a story and
then they say oh like I wrote myself
into a corner time travel and then like
he'll basically he'll fix the problem
using time travel I really she'll fix
writing himself into a hole using time
travel time travels invoked here by
Donnie Cates but it's not invoked for
the purpose of like saving himself it's
invoked for the purpose of like allowing
this story to progress forward and so
what Donnie Cates does is he actually
has cosmic Ghost Rider's he'll Odin send
me to the Past send me to the point
where all of this began send me to the
point where Thanos was first born now
this is an important thing here the
reason why is because what this does
depending on how Donnie Cates wants to
do this this basically creates an
alternate reality so for those of you
guys who are not familiar with this
Marvel Comics it's been a long long time
since we talked about alternate
realities we talked about how they work
and how they function in the in Marvel
Comics you have the main Marvel Universe
but when it comes to alternate realities
its branch universe theater so for
example those of you guys who have
recently seen ant-man and wasp you're
familiar with quantum room and saw the
quantum realm is the Enigma force just
this enigmatic force of energy and
nobody really knows where it comes from
it just kind of permeates from the
Microverse and that's it but there was a
story where the Enigma Force had left
the left of Microverse bonded his self
to spider-man and spider-man became
Captain universe and so the question is
what happened to kept if if spider-man
never lost that power where is the
what-if story there's actually in Spider
versus there's a version of his
character that never lost you know all
that dubbed super crazy power and so
because of that you know what happens
here is in the main Marvel Universe a
significant event will take place
Senator Robert Kelly Charles Xavier more
McTaggart will be assassinated by
mystique and the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants that starts Days of Future past
hope
summer is the first meeting born after
the events of house of M when all the
mutants lose their powers or a huge
number of the mutants lose their powers
she goes on to initiate the six-second
war kills 1 million humans in 6 seconds
that kicks off bishops feature there's
all these different you know alternate
realities that exists out there and they
all come from a major singular event
that takes place now usually it's done
for the purpose of just the plot right
but like in universe inside the Marvel
Universe it has to be like the death of
a significant character whose existence
in the main Marvel Universe would see
them go on to impact the universe in a
very significant way and so when you
have like cosmic Ghost Rider showing up
at the home of Thanos when he was raised
first for him he's a baby with the
desire to annihilate him to kill him
that's a pretty significant thing and so
what this means is that from this point
going forward to the end of the story
presumably Donnie Cates has created an
alternate reality and so he can
basically do anything he wants to I have
no idea what his plans are but it's
genius because it allows him to create
this self-contained set of events that
do not impact the main Marvel Universe
so it really kind of works but when
cosmic Ghost Rider shows up here to
basically kill this baby baby version of
tano's baby Thanos immediately attacks
him you know a little fan oohs
immediately attacks him and it's amazing
to see it's actually pretty funny
because even as a baby Thanos with super
hardcore now in response to this the
Ghost Rider does the only thing you can
do which is initiate the penance stare
now if those of you guys who are not
familiar with this and Marvel Comics all
the spirits of vengeance except for
Robbie Reyes they all have what's called
the penance there and the penance stare
is very similar to Hellfire
any of you guys who remember like like
JT James he was created in 2008 it was
like Mighty Avengers number 13 by Bendis
uh and then he appeared in secret
warriors Nick Fury's personal not really
Avengers team you know just kind of his
own personal guard more or less but the
whole idea here was that JT James
basically wielded something called
Hellfire and Hellfire could be used for
a variety of different purposes but one
of the things that it could do is it
could like torment the soul of a person
and that's kind of what the penance
stare does the difference here is that
the pennant stare actually forces a
person to experience all the pain and
suffering they've ever inflicted on
anybody in their entire life and so the
result is that when he uses this on baby
Thanos
well baby Thanos is pure he hasn't
actually done anything yet so the
penance stare doesn't really work
nothing happens
what this means is that for cosmic Ghost
Rider he's kind of like this kids a
blank slate but this kid's not a bad guy
yet it's not like Santos was born
inherently bad
the origin of Thanos was somewhat
touched on by jim Starlin in the old I
mean really in everything in the old
like like Captain Marvel series in the
old power of warlock series and the the
various you know like it was it Thanos
the Thanos war you know during the
events are like warlock in the infinity
watch his his origin to a degree was
kind of spread all over the place it
wasn't until we got vanos rising that
actually consolidated all that
information over the course of 60 years
changed a few things added some things
in took some things away and then in
turn like gave us this full-on life and
times of Thanos story what this does is
it comes back and basically says that
you know and again Chris is kind of
alternate reality effect of well then
cosmic Ghost Rider because of the fact
that baby Thanos is a clean slate he
comes back and says fine then I'll take
this baby under my wing we will go
forward and we will do our own thing
what that thing is we don't know we have
no clue but I'm really really excited to
find out but I figured I would go ahead
and cover this first issue throw it out
to you guys you can see what you're
getting into
it's amazing like it's I mean Donnie
Cates is one of those guys I'll read
anything he writes like I don't care
what it is he he could write a story
about Batman staring at a white wall and
I would read it it would be um it'd be
like the most amazing thing ever
maybe it'd be super cool but still if
you guys are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoy this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]